so here's the three steps identify an
older video that gets views every month
two change one thing don't do two things
at once in marketing we call this split
testing and in a split test you don't
change the thumbnail and the title you
change just the title you see the
results you go okay cool you make a
conclusion then you could go back and
change the thumbnail but you don't do
two things at a time and in Split
testing on like a landing page of
marketing there's like the headline
there could be the copy there could be
the images there could be the website
colors there could be the button colors
when you split test thing there could be
the copy on the buttons you just change
one thing though because if you change
too many variables
and then then it mixes
uh it dilutes the data of your
conclusion you're like oh wow it's
performing better but you're not sure
why it's performing better so you
isolate one thing so you're going to
identify an older video that gets views
every month you're going to change one
thing the title or the thumbnail and
then you're gonna watch The Impressions
over the next three to seven days so
this was a video this is how I would do
it I went into
think media podcast real-time views I
found a video by the way we're actually
talking about making a winner win more
because look this video
is got 81 000 views already the blue
line of view growth is outperforming the
typical performance on the channel
pretty cool it's 138 days old great so
here's what here's now exactly how you
would measure this
so you can go into the video
you can go to reach
Impressions it's gotten 1.3 million
Impressions total across its whole
lifetime it's gotten a 2.9 click-through
rate now imagine this imagine if that
was even just 3.1
um 1.3 million impressions that's a lot
more views imagine if that was four
percent on 1.3 so so a small tweaks lead
to Giant Peaks a small tweak to the
click-through rate
can have leads to significantly more
views depending on how many Impressions
a video is getting but Sean how would I
measure
if I change the thumbnail whether it's
been successful or not am I trying to
like put a microscope and see if the
line moves no no there's an actual
mathematical way to do it so what you're
going to do is you're going to go last
seven days
and what you're going to see on a video
like this that in the last seven days
click-through rate was 3.3 and you can
see that every single day the video has
been arranging September 12th when was
that September 12th was a Tuesday okay
so views might even though it's an old
video views might go up it looks like no
Impressions go up when we upload new
episodes and we upload new episodes on
Tuesday that's a hypothesis I'm just
guessing and then they they're a little
bit higher than they dropped the video
also might just be kind of on a decline
so how could we review revive this okay
so let's say we change one thing can I
improve this thumbnail so change the
thumbnail and then wait and you don't
gotta wait a week necessary you might
know in a few hours but then what you're
going to want to see is is YouTube
serving this to more people or less are
Impressions going up or even if
impressions are staying the same as
click through rate going up so if this
if we change just the thumbnail
and then observe it over three four five
six seven days
and this goes to four and a half
it's when your mind starts to think I
mean drop an emoji if you're like this
is mind explode because it starts making
you dream like oh my gosh not only is
this video doing this but if I just
change this one thing and it improves
performance
then over time this video might get
thousands of more views so this would be
improving your winner and you could do
the exact same thing with the title you
could change just the title and see if
things stay the same and so what I'm
looking for that's the big key is I'm
looking for a video that's getting
consistent Impressions because if the
video is dead and you change the
thumbnail then you're not measuring it
against anything and if the video is
dead here's a mistake you could also
make and you go share it on your
community tab or like email your list to
go watch a video where you're bringing
traffic from external what we want is we
want a video that's getting impressions
based on the YouTube algorithm this is
getting suggested videos is the number
one traffic source and search is the
second traffic source
so it's this is already getting
consistent Impressions change the title
boom Oh sick let's leave it now you
might say well what if it actually goes
down what if the click-through rate goes
down what if impression starts to drop
flip it back just remember what your
prior title was and it'll at least
revert and balance out to what it was
previously
or uh try another one try another split
test another test and what you
ultimately could do
is then see that
um okay cool now I have verified that
this thumbnail performs better and now I
have verified that this title uh after
the thumbnail is verified then you could
also do the title as well so that would
be up to you two things number one I've
had too much coffee today number two if
you have not seen our free master class
yet you're gonna love it if you're
serious about growing your YouTube
channel just go to
thinkmasterclass.com for a one hour Deep
dive on-demand YouTube strategy class
it's sick and uh I'm gonna go refill my
coffee hope to see you on the class